fishing kits found in the wild the all
new ibm cloud bare metal servers for vpc
and a new certification from the ibm
center for cloud training all on this
episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
i wanted to start this week with a bit
of security related news a team of
academics recently discovered more than
twelve hundred fishing kits equipped
with the ability to intercept users
two-factor authentication codes
many of the toolkits use
man-in-the-middle phishing to bypass
two-factor authentication procedures by
working as reverse proxies
this means that when the affected user
did succeed in authenticating themselves
on a legitimate service the reverse
proxy also gave the attacker access to a
copy of the authentication cookie
with the cookie the attacker could
access the account to steal information
or even sell it on the dark net
unfortunately phishing attacks reached
unprecedented heights in 2021 it's
important that organizations protect
themselves by blending multi-factor
authentication and other technical
controls with stringent education for
all employees
to learn more about these phishing
attacks and how to protect yourself
check out the blog linked below
next up you know what you get with bare
metal servers on a classic
infrastructure dedicated compute with
direct hardware access for your
performance oriented workloads
but what about speed high availability
and interconnectivity what about having
a truer on-demand provisioning option
for your most intense applications
to meet these needs i'm excited to
introduce you to the all-new ibm cloud
bare metal servers for vpc
bare metal servers for vpc give you the
benefits of bare metal with faster
provisioning and better network design
and performance
this solution takes the dedicated
performance single tendency consistency
and security of a bare metal server and
introduces more quality of life
improvements
it also unlocks larger core and memory
profiles client managed virtualization
and faster network performance all
without the need for a gateway to
connect classic and vpc infrastructures
to learn more about how to get started
with ibm cloud bare metal servers for
vpc hit the link below
finally to wrap things up i want to
shine a spotlight on the new ibm cloud
security engineer specialty
certification from the ibm center for
cloud training
this new program provides an interactive
curriculum that trains professionals to
identify and remediate vulnerabilities
respond to security incident escalations
and proactively engineer security and
compliance best practices
by following this learning path you'll
learn how to secure infrastructure and
hybrid cloud connections cloud compute
kubernetes services and vmware solutions
in ibm cloud you'll also explore how to
manage access controls and authorization
and the configuration of security and
compliance solutions
courses and exams are available now and
you can learn more by clicking on the
link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you